welcome everyone this is rob sanders
with simply learn
and welcome today we're going to talk
about email marketing tutorial
so buckle up and let's get started and
talk about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda
it's an efficient way to convert leads
into sales
why because we can send personalized
emails to a specific audience a targeted
audience
if somebody's interested in our product
we can reach out to them via email
it can also be used to remarket
pre-qualified leads
so anybody who's pre-qualified we can go
ahead
and communicate with them as well so
email marketing is a very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration
purchase retention and advocacy okay so
let's talk about each one of these parts
of the
funnel or customer life cycle if you
will so let's start with awareness at
the very top
so email marketing allows customers to
recognize
their problems after which you can
educate them on how your brand can solve
them okay
just like any other marketing channel
somebody's looking for something
in need of something and we can come to
the rescue in this case we're going to
come to the rescue
with email and we can go ahead and
educate them on
on what their need is and how we can
collaborate with them
help them educate them solve their
problems with our product okay
so that's what email's going to do we're
going to communicate with them via email
and we're going to bring awareness to
the problem by solving the problem
that's what email is good for
okay good for generating awareness for
our brand
for example we can share a newsletter
with our customers
so we're running a cosmetics company
we can basically educate them on the
five important skin care products that
everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more
so if somebody's having some skin care
issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so
customers focused on searching for
relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely
looking they're a little further in the
process they're educated they know what
they're looking for
so we can really hit them with the right
email we can send a relevant email to
promote
our product okay discover that perfect
moisturizer for your skin
perfect skin moisturizer smooths
hydrates and contains spf 20. so we got
the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel
and really is ready to purchase that
product so we can hit that person up
with the perfect messaging talk about
purchase the next step
in the life cycle well purchase well
with purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer
purchase our product by offering them
something
okay by giving an offer for example we
can give a discount
discounts always tend to work so that
moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying
well they can move from consideration to
purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so
you know it could beat for a specific
date okay
it could be you know something that's
going to get them excited to buy the
product 20
off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other
products they were considering buying so
getting somebody that
extra incentive to purchase the product
goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
life cycle and nurture
our relationship with customers to
ensure they're
loyal okay they've already purchased how
do we get them
purchased again that's retention we want
to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product
or similar products or completely
different products in our inventory
so what do we do we're going to send an
email we're going to send an
email to active customers okay we're
going to give
them an offer just for them exclusively
just for them in this example we're
gonna give them a combo pack a facial
kit at just
39 and get a sunscreen worth ten dollars
for free
so you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations
on offers key is the offer is
exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers
because if you just get somebody to
purchase once it's not going to work
those people have already taken the that
step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and
treat that customer special by giving
them an exclusive offer
and then what we want to do is advocacy
last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer
into brand advocates okay we want that
customer
to talk about our brand for us we want
them to promote it and talk about it
with your friends
so for example we want to send an email
to those customers to promote our
products
okay so for example we could say hey the
sales of our products for this
particular day or for this month
is going to go to our favorite
non-profit could be educating poor
children
or cleaning up plastic in the ocean or
saving animals we want to be able to get
them to speak on our behalf and say look
guys this is a really good company you
know they're offering me
products exclusively they've offered me
discounts in the past they have good
products they have a lot of different
products
and on top of all that they help they
help the environment
they help the needy okay they care and
so
we can go ahead and provide a call to
action
for these customers that are loyal to
our brand
and have them share the email with their
friends to spread the word
on you know what we're trying to
accomplish for our non-profit or
if anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount
for every friend that they get to buy
our product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be
that extra incentive of giving them a
discount if they do share with friends
and their friends buy
okay so this is the customer life cycle
and examples of different emails that
you can use at every step
along the way in the life cycle so let's
talk about
email marketing set up so email
marketing set up we have a series of
steps that we need to go through
in order to get our email set up
to go ahead and send out to our target
audience and that first step
is we want to identify that target
audience and create
segments so if you've taken some of my
and listened to some of my webinars in
the past about google analytics
about google ads we talk about
segmenting
so it's about targeting a specific
audience that's what segmenting is
taking a piece of the whole so we don't
want to email all users
on our list all customers maybe we want
to target a specific
segment okay so we want to be able to
identify that segment who is that
segment is it somebody who
or a group of people or you know a
partial list
of our customers who purchase a specific
product
i would say so versus say our entire
list of customers because our entire
list of customers can purchase
a number of different products and so by
targeting a specific
segment of our audience or our customer
base
we can hone in on the message so if they
all have something in common like they
all bought that moisturizer
then we can go ahead and be specific
with our messaging
then we want to create campaigns and set
an appropriate call to action okay so
what is it that we want to say to these
these people this segment
of users then once you create that
campaign and
and set up the messaging and call to
action we want to test the email
before we actually click send this is a
very important step
test that email before we send
and then when we send the campaigns
immediately or we can
schedule a time so my advice here is
always schedule a time you want to be
able
to figure out the best time to send that
email
and then once the email is sent whenever
that is you want to be able to analyze
performance
and there are some key metrics that you
want to hone
in on when we talk about email marketing
and some of those are
open rates click-through rates okay
response rate okay so
we want to be able to hone in on certain
key
metrics when it comes to emails so
here's what we need to do
create our list add contacts to our list
create our campaign
okay we want to select the list choose a
format
modify the template and then send the
email campaign so
these are some basic checklists that you
want to do so let me give you an example
and go to mailchimp so if i'm in
mailchimp
basically i'm going to create a campaign
okay
so it's an email that i'm going to work
with
and you can see with mailchimp i have
some some examples here regular
automated
plain text or a b test i want to do a
regular email
and i'm just going to call it test and
i'm going to click begin
okay so we want to add our recipients
who are we going to add so we're going
to choose
our audience okay so
we're just going to choose a sample test
for now okay
we can personalize the two fields if we
want
okay so what do we want to do we want to
call people by their first name their
last name the first
and last name where we can customize it
just go with first name to keep it a
little bit personal
okay then we have the subject line here
so it's all about
messaging right so whoever we're
targeting
we want to be able to add a message so
we're just going to say and and subject
line is very key here so
you want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that
segment audience is we want to make sure
that the subject line is going to
resonate with
with them so that they can open up that
email okay
so uh we'll just say having a good day
we can make it better just as an example
something that's going to be
attention grabbing if you will okay you
can always tweak the subject line
in fact my advice is always do
a b testing on the subject line so you
can do two different
subject lines with one email to figure
out which one has better open rates
and then with mailchimp we can go ahead
and design the content
of our email so we're going to click
design email okay we can
select a template we have some save
templates already
okay or we can go with a theme so
mailchimp has a lot of good offers now
there's a lot of different
email platforms out there i particularly
like mailchimp because
of this very feature they have a lot of
good themes here
um a lot of different layouts that you
can use okay so you know we're gonna
showcase that product
okay and that's the template we're gonna
use here so here we go
we're gonna showcase our product we're
gonna add that photo of our product here
and we're gonna go ahead and put some
nice messaging in here
with some nice call to action we can put
our logo up here for branding
again we can edit the content here so
based on that
segmented list in this example for
linda's company maybe she wants to
target those folks
who bought her moisturizer before her
face
moisturizer and she wants to retarget
them she wants to go ahead and say hey
you guys have bought my product before
check out this
new face moisturizer that we have to
offer so whatever
the case is you want to be able to plan
that out ahead of time you want to be
able to plan out who your audience is
you want to plan out your messaging and
you want to
go ahead and set up the messaging based
on that audience
so once you have the messaging in place
voila you're more or less
ready to go okay so once you get the
content all set up
you can schedule that campaign okay and
you can
also add a social post to your campaign
so we can share that information
on social so email integrates nicely
with social media
so again that's that's pretty much what
you need to do
here you need to really think about who
it is you want to target
choose those recipients okay customize
it
and make it personal create a good
subject line in fact create two subject
lines
and then align that content with that
audience
okay that's that's really the checklist
here so again we look at this checklist
creating our list who do we want to send
the email to so we added our contacts to
the list
we set up the campaign we selected the
list
we chose the format we modified it with
a good subject line
with some good messaging and then we're
going to schedule that email campaign
so that's the checklist to go off okay
so remember identify target audience and
create segments
then you create that campaign and in our
case we did set an appropriate call to
action
you know get shopping basically we want
people to shop our new moisturizer
key thing here is before we send it out
we want to test
that email once everything looks good
we're going to
i would advise schedule it but you can
always send the email when you're ready
i would schedule it at the appropriate
time and day okay so in this case you
don't want to send an email out on a
friday afternoon
okay when people are getting ready for
the weekend you certainly don't want to
send an email out over the weekend
because
you're not going to have many people
look and open it and you probably don't
want to send the email out on a monday
morning when most people are
getting into the office from a long
weekend
and catching up on emails so from my
experience
you know tuesday wednesday depending on
your time zone i would always say
you know late morning early afternoon
tends to be a good time but
that's why we have performance that's
why we can analyze performance
we want to be able to see what the open
rates are and the click-through rates
are so that we can make adjustments for
future emails so let's talk about
some of those metrics so when you do
send that email
you know we're gonna look at that open
so open rate is the percentage of the
total number of recipients who open
an email so okay so if we basically
you know send it to x amount of people
minus those emails that have bounced so
let's just say
you know we sent it to a hundred and two
people
okay for simplicity's sake two of those
emails bounced
okay so that means that we've had a
hundred net
100 emails that received the email and
let's just say 75 open the email
okay we wrote such a good subject line
that
they opened it okay that's 75 that's a
75 percent open rate that's how you
measure
open rate click through rate okay so if
they open it
we hope that they click on something and
so
for all of those emails that were
delivered okay in this case a hundred
how many actually did click on our call
to action so
let's just say 75 opened it
out of the 100 that's a 75 open rate but
of the hundred that actually were
delivered let's just say
we had 25 that actually clicked
on the call to action and so that's 25
okay and so you want to be able to
measure not only who
opens it but who clicks on the call to
action so that's click-through rate for
email marketing
and then response rate so it's the
percentage of the total recipients
who clicked on a link of your email
campaign and actually completed the
action
so in our example we're trying to get
people to click on the shopping call to
action
and get them to purchase so we sent 100
emails
and of the 25 who actually clicked
we had 10 who actually took action and
purchase
so 10 divided by 100 is 10
so you have open rate click through rate
and response rate those are some
key metrics for email marketing okay the
first step is you got to get people to
open it that's where the subject line
is so important click their way that's
where the messaging and call to action
is so important we want to get people to
click on that call to action
and then the response rate we want them
to buy so those are our three key
metrics related to email marketing
so let's take a look at an example if we
go back to our email marketing platform
mailchimp in this example we're going to
take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms
have reporting functionality built in
and so in this case
what we want to do is we want to be able
to take a look at the open rate
click-through rates of the emails that
have been sent out previously
so here we could see our april email
coupon versus tools promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens
and clicks so 14 open rate
1.4 click-through rate okay so
the march email that went out did a
little bit better 19
open two and a half percent on the
click-through rate
so here we could see how many people
actually
were sent how many opened it and how
many clicks so this is a mailchimp makes
it very
easy for us to measure you know open and
click rates and then
we can measure by revenue as well based
on
the campaign so that's measuring the
response rate
so it's all built in so most email
marketing platforms
have open rate and click rate already
built into the functionality
so you can measure those two metrics
against
any email so let's talk about the
benefits of
email marketing so what are some of the
benefits
well we've already mentioned to linda
that it's cost effective
it's time saving real-time marketing
less intrusive builds credibility
increases
visibility and brand awareness and it's
an easy way to track roi
these are all the benefits for email
marketing we're gonna go
talk about some of these now so
basically when we talk about
cost effective you know some email
marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me
to set up that email campaign the key is
figuring out who you want to send it to
when we talk about real-time marketing
you know we're sending this
email out basically in real time
trying to meet our customers needs at
the right time
it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can
as you saw i can put first name in there
to make it more
personal so when something's more
personal it's less intrusive especially
if it's a segment that already knows
your brand okay builds credibility hey
we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy
by working with nonprofits okay it
increases visibility and brand awareness
why because
you know we could send our email out to
a large
group of people and that's a good way to
generate brand awareness and as you saw
we can easily measure
you know not only open rates click rates
but roi
so how many people from that email went
on and purchased so we can measure that
it's very easy to measure email so let's
move into
a b testing so a b testing is
key to email marketing okay so in email
marketing
gaining high open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory
that's what's supposed to happen we get
more opens we get more people to click
we get more people to click we're gonna
get more people to purchase
okay but it's not as easy as it sounds
so how do we make that possible well
we're gonna do that
via a b testing i've already mentioned
it when i set up my example
campaign in mailchimp i stressed and
stressed and stressed
that we need to have two subject lines
go out
per email okay so before i stress that
again
let me just reiterate what a b testing
is and a b testing is a method to
analyze
which of the two email campaign
strategies most effective
in terms of high open rates and click
rates okay so in this case
an a b testing you can send out two
emails you can send out two subject
lines you can send out two call to
actions
you're just really what you're doing is
you're testing one
against the other that's what a b
testing is and so
in my example i talked about that
subject line so for better results a b
testing can be done with the subject
line can also be done with the email
content
so the subject line impacts the open
rate okay so i wrote a subject line i
don't even know how that subject line is
going to perform
but if i write a second subject line
then
i'll be able to basically give myself a
better chance of getting a better open
rate because i'm offering up
two different subject lines likewise for
email content
so the subject line and email content
are the most important elements
so we want to be able to test them if
they're interesting intriguing
uh attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates
if the content itself is interesting
engaging
a good offer a good call to action then
the click rates are going to be
increased so we want to be able to serve
up variations for
our audience so we want to consider an
example of an a b
test where linda has set up two
variations
of the email campaign as an example so
she's gonna send two different subject
lines to test
which one generates more open rates
because that's what
subject line a b testing is going to do
one of them is going to have a higher
open rate okay
so in our example here linda sends
version a
of the email to 50 of the recipients
with
the subject line three important
strategies to increase your open rate
well
version b which is sent to the other 50
percent
has the subject line three important
strategies to increase
your open rate so the only difference
here is
three and three the number three spelled
out well
because she sent out two different
subject lines she's going to now
be able to measure the success of that a
b test
okay and it just so happens version a
has a higher open rate
numbers always tend to work in subject
lines by the way
so linda sends version a of the email to
50
of the recipients okay 80 today but
dollars tomorrow and version b to the
remaining fifty percent
eighty dollars today ninety dollars
tomorrow and the only
really succinct difference here is using
the word
but versus a comma and she sent that
email out
and that email went out and the date is
coming in and she's going to measure the
success of that a b test
well version b has the higher open rate
you know we want to be short succinct
and stay away from those conjugations
like but
okay it tends to have a negative
connotation so the shorter
more direct email our subject line 80
today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
high open rates another example here
version a
again gets 50 with the subject line
uh-oh
your prescription is expiring version b
your prescription is expiring you folks
listen to this webinar right now i
wonder
which one you think will perform go
ahead and put your comments
right below this video i'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open
so let's go ahead and measure the
success of the a b
test okay so she sent the email out two
different subject lines
fifty percent got one subject line the
other fifty percent got the other
subject line
and it just so happens version a
uh-oh your prescription is expiring
there's a little bit of a
you know personalization to that you
know for me your prescription is
expiring
seems to be a little bit more you know
command-ish
hey your prescription's expiring so we
expect you to purchase
where you have a little uh oh in front
it's like hey
you know i think your prescription is
expiring maybe you should think about
renewing it okay i think that's how
that's interpreted at least that's how i
interpret it so i would probably go
ahead and click on that email with that
subject line so you could see
subtle differences in the subject lines
make a big difference in open rates so
in order to keep improving those open
rates you need to continue
and not continue should always do
subject line
testing always because one subject line
is always going to have a better open
write than the other
so always do a b testing when it comes
to subject lines
and email content for that matter okay
so
we're always going to do continuous a b
testing so
with continuous a b testing we can test
very
various elements of the email so you can
always test the sender's name the
subject line the copy the call to action
the design the imagery
there's a lot of different elements you
can test
with emails for example center's name
okay so you want to personalize it as
much as you can
okay you don't want to do a no reply
you want it to come from a human being
in this case sam
okay at least that's what i think let's
see what the
test states no surprise version a
has the higher open rate if you
customize these things and personalize
them
then it goes a long way sending an email
from a no reply is not
a good best practice let's talk about
the subject line again uh so we got
webinar
increase your email open rates webinar
increase your email open rates
so the webinar is dynamic on version a
okay so we're sending that out and
because it's dynamic
that's going to you know beat out the
static
webinar increase your email open rates a
lot more elements we can test here
so for example the email copy so learn
some easy ways to increase your email
open rates join us on may 10
2019 7 p.m for an interactive discussion
with our experts
well version b is more personalized it's
a same message
but we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case
rachel so we can measure the success of
the a b
test but it's no surprise that anything
that's customized that
comes from somebody a name you know with
a dynamic
email subject line is going to perform
better it's going to increase
open rates and it's going to increase
click rates so
we can also test that call to action the
difference here
is coloring save my seat yellow versus
save my c
blue again go ahead and play along here
if you're watching this go ahead and add
a comment and just see if you're right
do you think it's blue
or you think it's yellow on the call to
action color
does go a long way in email marketing so
let's measure the success of this a b
test and it just so happens yellow is
going to perform better why does yellow
perform better than blue
what's more positive plus it it kind of
resonates a little bit stronger
and easier okay it stands out a little
bit better
it's not as pastely and dull as this
shade of blue we're using
so you can see here we're testing every
bit of the elements of the email
anything from the from
to the subject line to the message to
the call to action
and so at the end of the day you know
you want to be able to
send out the best email that's going to
give you the best results
so we're going to send that out the
entirety of the email
and we could see version a looks a lot
better and why does version a look a lot
better in this example because look at
the font
size is a little bit bigger version b
font size smaller harder to read that's
another thing you can test
larger fonts tend to do a little bit
better now you don't want to go
overboard and have them
you know 48 points or 50 points and plus
you know 14 versus 12 goes a long way
we can continue testing we can test
imagery
you can see here we have a hand aligned
with the call to action
they just look different that's all
version a has
one type of hand version b has the other
type of hand
aligned with the call to action let's go
ahead and send out that test and see
what works well
version b works why the hand stands out
a little bit more clear
it doesn't blend in with the call to
action so
you can see we're testing different
elements here and we're always
improving and adding to what's working
so we started out with
a no reply versus somebody's name
then we move to a subject line then we
move to
personalization then we move to
you know call to action then we move to
an increased font
meaning the design and then we're adding
imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test
eventually you're going to get to a
point where you know the email is going
to be good and you're going to
just continue to test different options
on it
to continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates final output
looks like this again that personalized
email response
from sam versus no reply you know we got
a nice dynamic
subject line gotta personalize the email
to rachel with larger font
okay we got a nice call to action that
stands out
with a nice image to accompany that so
we've tested all these different
elements this is the best
combination based on everything we
tested so when we get that email to go
this is what it's going to look like in
the future but guess what we're not
going to stop
testing so we can continue to test those
subject lines continue to test the
messaging and continue to test the email
design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images
you're never going to stop testing with
email marketing
okay so let's switch over to how to
optimize
the subject line subject line is such a
key component to email marketing
so as we showed you in the last segment
we tested a subject line
and we used a number the number three
versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line your emails come a long way
emojis aren't just social media based
you can
use emojis in subject lines i'd highly
recommend it you know i just sat
on an email last month with the subject
line about
you know spring showers bring may
flowers and guess what emoji i had in
that subject line
a flower okay may sound cheesy but it
goes a long way
so according to experian subject lines
with emojis can increase
open rates by 45 percent people resonate
with emojis especially if they're
positive emojis okay so we want to
personalize those subject lines for
better
open rate okay when i say personalize
don't be so stale
remember that subject line we tested uh
oh just putting
uh-oh in there made it sound like we
actually cared it was a little bit
personal it wasn't so personal you
weren't dressing a specific
person but one little word goes a long
way in a subject line because when
people get emails and they read emails
and a lot of people are inundated with
emails
the subject line is what they're reading
first and just by
personalizing it adding a number adding
an
emoji
just making it positive and easy to read
they're likely to open on email
so personalized email messages can
improve
click through rate and open rates as
well so you want to personalize your
email as much as you can
whether that be from the from field to
putting that person's name
and the salutation so personalized
subject lines have been found to
increase
open rates by up to 50 so don't come
across
as spammy come across as you know who
your audience is and you're talking to
them
and then you want to prefer title case
subject lines
so title case subject lines for example
when i say
title case game of thrones is my
favorite show
every initial letter in that title
is capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case game of thrones is my
favorite show
it doesn't stand out as much of course
if you go with lower case
it definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and
somebody's probably not going to open it
so you always go with that title case
the
every initial letter gets capitalized
so how to optimize that subject line
well watch the length of your subject
line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters
you want to keep it short succinct and
to the point but personalized with an
emoji
with initial caps on each word to make
it stand out
but you have to do that within 70 10 17
and 24 characters
so according to campaign monitor the
ideal length of a subject line
is up to 24 characters and they're more
likely to boost those email rates
okay so keep it short make it impactful
make it personalized like i mentioned
before
if you get too long then it may get cut
off and it may not
have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why
we always recommend keeping it up to
about 24 characters okay if you go over
by a couple characters
not the end of the world but try and
stay within that range
develop a sense of urgency okay so when
we say sense of urgency
we mean sense of urgency meaning if that
coupon is going to expire
you know you want to let people know
it's going to expire that day or the
next day or within a few days
okay so you can use things like hurry up
or limit
offer or limited stock or offer expires
on
okay so add a bit of sense of urgency i
mean
sky's not falling here but if that
coupon's expiring
at the end of the week you probably want
to mention something
to the effect of hey offers expiring or
hurry up
so let's talk about optimizing your
email content so we focused a lot on
subject lines let's talk about the email
content itself
so some ways to optimize email content
are we want to send the content that is
relevant to
customer expectations so content needs
to match that expectation
we want to use bullet points to make the
content readable
we want to follow logical structure we
want to use compelling imagery
and prefer design emails with responsive
designs and what we mean by responsive
design
is hey most people are going to be
checking that email
on their mobile phone okay so make sure
when you design the email
it's also going to be good not just on
desktop but on tablet and mobile as well
and then of course just goes without
saying but avoid grammatical mistakes
go ahead and spell checked it and that's
why we put an emphasis on
testing your email before you actually
send it and when you actually
send an email test email don't send it
to yourself
send it to colleagues you know send it
to another group a fresh set of eyes
a fresh set of eyes like it's going to
be able to pick out
that misspelled word that you overlooked
so
i can't stress the sending of the test
email because
it's going to be able to you know in a
way
ensure that you're doing everything on
this list in addition to grammatical
mistakes you know
the person who's receiving your test
email your colleague at work
may be looking at that email on their
mobile phone and if it doesn't look good
to them
they're going to let you know some other
ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the a
b testing you always want to personalize
it
question is hey do i use first name do i
use first and last name
well guess what you can test that but
you want to personalize it okay you want
to choose the right fonts and colors for
your email
so when we were going through some
examples on testing
you know i always tend to go a little
bit larger on the font
but you can play around with it i don't
think you should probably
use white lettering on a black
background that just
is not very good or best practice
but go ahead and try it if you want okay
you can always play around
and test these but you want to choose
something that's really going to
resonate
with the recipient of the email okay you
want to build a rapport with customers
by
sharing insights they value for example
the beginning of this webinar we talked
about advocacy we talked about
you know sharing with them some of the
non-profits that
we work with as a company okay if we
have a
you know cosmetics company and we have
different products like moisturizers
and facial creams we may want to state
that hey we don't use
any animals in the testing of these
products you know we're pro
animal we're not you know we're not
going to use animals in the testing of
our products
and that probably resonates with a lot
of your customers so you want to
go ahead and build a rapport with those
customers by sharing those insights
okay and use recipient names and you
always want to
personalize it then add a clear call to
action at the end you always want to
have that call to action
regardless of what the email is hey it
could be just a simple
read more or hey donate it doesn't have
to
always be so hardcore in terms of hey
purchase our product
that could be a turn off especially if
you're sending emails out once a week to
your customer base they're constantly
hammering them
with buy now buy now by now they're
going to get turned off so you want to
mix
up the call to actions and that goes
back to the very first step
and what kind of email are you going to
send out who are you going to send it to
so you have to align those two with
somebody who doesn't even know who your
brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of buy now
you're probably going to say hey check
us out we have some cool
stuff for you so i want to thank you if
you need any more information
please visit simplylearn.com if you have
anything to add
certainly go ahead and comment below
this video we'd love
to get your comments on the subject and
of course we'll respond accordingly
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here